now to the kardashian sisters biggest
relationship reveals from their 24-hour
press blitz so you wanted to get married
for real but we're unable to get married
for real there's nothing more than you'd
want for everyone to be happy kanye and
i will always be family first which of
kimye's kids know about their nasty
divorce my two older ones they know
what's going on and you just have to
have a really open dialogue with your
children kim says she and kanye still
talk and according to our source kanye
told his ex he's going away to get help
and has agreed to stop harassing kim and
cyber bullying pete davidson
next the sweet gift pete gave kim to
remember their first kiss on snl
actually for valentine's day he got me
the rug in the whole outfit he did and
the little genie oh wow
outside jimmy kimmel live last night
paparazzi booed kim and her family for
seemingly blowing them off inside
courtney dished on her drunken practice
wedding we didn't know it was fake
married it's not called fake marriage it
is called that there was there was no
like possibility to get a marriage
license at that hour as for which family
members were aware of the 2am vegas
nuptials i knew and chloe knew i was on
facetime i was sleeping i woke up to
like a million tucks i see i see finally
is there still hope for chloe and ex
tristan thompson she answered that on
their abc news special he cheated on me
right before i gave birth and i was able
to still have him in the delivery room i
still think he's a great guy and he's a
great dad he's just not the guy for me
[Music]